[Music]
hello everyone
messed up the intro a little bit there
but uh here we are
live again with chess openings explained
uh today of course the line that i want
to walk you guys through
is the fischer sozen attack in the night
or of course it was a favorite
of bobby fischer with the white pieces
and so that's why i put his picture on
the stream today
but uh basically
what this line is is one of the more
aggressive variations in the nidorf
it is one of the more theory heavy
variations depending on
what you choose to play with the black
pieces
and uh there are quite a fun quite a few
fun lines that i want to show you guys
tonight
and probably this is going to take so
long that it will need
uh another lecture but we'll save that
for now for later i guess
uh let's just jump into it the sozing
starts with e4
c5 knight f3 d6 d4
c takes d4 knight takes d4
knight f6 knight c3 and a6
arriving at the night or of course the
first two
uh lectures in the series were focused
around the bishop e2 lines
which are sort of the the calmer slower
more uh positional sort of variations
and now today
i want to take a look at the move bishop
c4 on move six this is sort of a
one of the main variations in the nia
dwarf to
learn and to understand and this is the
start of the sosen
or fischer sozen however you want to uh
to say it
and black's next move is actually going
to be really really natural
so our opponent develops this bishop out
to c4
rather than a square like e2 obviously
this is a more aggressive square
against the bishop e2 lines we love to
play the move e5
force this knight away and then we can
develop our pieces rather naturally
behind this e pawn with bishop c4
this is going to be a little bit harder
to achieve if you play the move e5 here
um already the move knight to f5 is
going to be
uh the the issue this of course isn't
really playable after bishop e2
but here white has enough control over
the d5 square
to go ahead and play in this manner
so rather than a move like e5 the move
e6
comes to mind uh and this is the move
that is the main move here in the night
earth and the idea
is to stunt this bishop on c4
and now the variations that we're going
to look at tonight
basically all are all revolve around
these lines
where white is trying to break through
on e6 square
and so i'm going to talk about uh what
i'm going to recommend with black
and what white should really be doing
against it
so how can white break through this e6
square well there's really two main ways
uh way number one is eventually you'll
see a piece sacrifice on e6 that's
definitely one way to do it
but the main main idea in many of the
fisher sews and attack lines
is to go f4 f5 and sort of chomp at this
e6 guy
in this manner and so the line i'm going
to recommend
tonight is a pretty complex one
and the idea is basically to play
against this idea
of f4 and f5 by white
so after e6 there are really two main
moves
uh white can go ahead and castle but
much more common is just to play the
move bishop b3
uh and this bishop drops back to b3 for
a number of reasons
the more obvious one is to step out of
any b5 pushes with tempo
but also occasionally black is going to
be pushing the move
d5 and this would also be hitting the
bishop so it makes sense drop the bishop
back
to a nice defended square here on b3
uh and now the main moves are to play b5
immediately
or to play knight bd7 here but i'm
actually going to recommend
that you play the move bishop e7
in this case and now these lines get
very very
uh complex uh perhaps one of the
critical variations
is for white to play g4 and i think we
are going to save this line actually
for the next lecture or if i end up
having time i will start going through
these variations here as well
but for tonight i want to focus on the
main plan with
f4 and uh this this f5 idea
f4 can also be combined with the idea of
e5 as
as we will see and so after white plays
the move
f4 of course white can also castle here
transposing into the line
uh where white castles here if bishop b7
bishop e3
is by far the most common move uh so
bishop b3
bishop b7 and castles with transpose
so let's take a look at f4 and
now after f4 uh things go a little bit
wild the move i'm actually going to
recommend is
a bit of a sideline and the point here
is that i want to play the move b5 uh
immediately after this move
f4 arrives on the board and this is a
move
uh that has actually only been played
looks like 13
times in the database and so
understandably
uh there are some complex lines where
white can try and pose
some difficult problems to black however
i'm hoping
i've done a number of hours of analysis
of these variations uh i'm hoping black
is is doing just fine
in pretty much all of them uh i will say
that a lot of these lines are theory
heavy
and i've mentioned that i'm using a few
different resources to prepare these
lectures
one of which is an excellent book by
alex korovich
on chesable where uh he goes over
some lines in the nightdorf it's called
the night or simplified i believe
and so if you want a slightly easier
variation than the one i'm going to be
recommending here today
i would definitely recommend checking
out that chest pull course uh
because i think the the lines that he
recommended are a little bit simpler for
black but i i do think these are
quite a bit more fun so b5 is the move
i'm gonna recommend
and now in the database uh there are a
few different moves that have been
played
the move f5 has been played here the
move castles has been played here
the move e5 has been played and then
bishop e3
a3 and queen f3 all have you know one or
one or two
uh examples and the most common moves
are f5 and king side castles here
uh those have been played together 21
times
and i think both of those moves actually
lead to a pretty decent
advantage or at least a very comfortable
position for black
the main line you actually have to look
out for
is going to be this move e5 and that's
where things get rather complex
and i think this is probably the reason
this is not seen
too too often so we're definitely going
to delve deep
into these e5 lines but for the moment
let's take a look
uh i guess we'll go briefly over some
lines after e5
d takes e5 f takes e5 knight f to d7
and now there are really two critical
variations bishop takes e6
and queen g4 uh which i'm definitely
going to go over
but first just to give you some idea of
the kind of position we're dealing with
if white plays rather slowly let's say
something
like bishop f4 or queen e2 just to
defend this pawn
well black is actually going to already
have a pretty sizable advantage because
e5
is going to be weak in the long run
white definitely needs to play
immediately here or he is very much
going to end up in a slightly suspicious
position so for example bishop b7
is natural development now is something
like rook f1
going after this guy a simple knight c6
and white is going to have to sacrifice
immediately
if he doesn't just plays like bishop e3
well black's gonna castle
and these pawns are already hanging
or just a simple development by black
and if
black can achieve this then black is
like i said going to be significantly
better here
moves like knight c5 are coming and
moves like b4
are going to be coming as well and this
is just going to sort of fall apart
quite quickly
for white the attack on the king side
isn't really going anywhere
you see all of white's pieces are
honestly kind of stranded over here on
the queen side
uh why would white play e4 well we're
going to get over the critical
variations
uh in a minute so bishop takes e6 should
be played and now if we actually capture
this bishop
uh we're going to be in a pretty
dangerous uh territory here i think
black is lost
if you capture the bishop because this
attack is just far too strong
with pieces coming in the e5 pawn on the
board but luckily black has a very very
good move here
uh with king side castles uh and after
this move
black should be doing quite quite well
uh white has to solve the issue of this
bishop the e5 pawn is hanging
and he has to solve the problem of what
to do with these two pieces
on the now half open soon to be fully
open e file
as well for example if knight takes c6
ships e6 and the bishop retreats uh you
can already imagine a move like b4
knight d5 and bishop b5 and uh
white could quite quickly be losing
material
uh okay so that's your brief
introduction on the position after the
move e5
if white tries to play slowly something
like queen e2 we just develop our pieces
get castled and don'ts allow any bishop
takes e6 sacrifices
if white does take on e6 more often than
not kingside castles is going to be more
than enough
for an advantage for black rather than
accepting the piece
in these main e5 lines that i'm talking
about
once again those moves we just developed
naturally and then end up
already winning material uh okay
so let's move on now to the critical
lines
so jumping in here we have once again
the same opening moves
uh e6 bishop b3 bishop e7
and f4 we're taking a look at now b5
and like i said i think f5 and kingside
castles
both lead to advantageous positions for
black which we're going to get to
eventually
but let's jump right in to the critical
variations after e5
so takes takes knight fd7 and now like i
said
these are the two critical moves to look
out for
every other move black can sort of just
develop normally
brief honorable mention to queen f3 i
should say as well
this move is uh not super critical you
just need to realize
that you can play the move queen c7 here
uh and now
queen takes a8 is not going to be very
good due to bishop b7
when this queen is totally trapped
uh so queen c7 and then play would sort
of develop normally something like rook
f1
kingside castles this bishop gets
developed
and something like bishop b7 and then
black is once again
doing quite well so uh back to the
critical variations let's start
with bishop takes e6 uh
now i spent a number of hours on this
move alone
trying to make different variations work
kingside castles has been played twice
from this position this position itself
has been reached seven times from the
database i'm using
and kingside castles was played twice
knight takes e5 was played five times
uh in the five games where knight takes
e5 was played there are two wins for
white and three draws and black won both
times he castled king's side
but i think castle's king's side
actually leads to an advantageous
position
for white the key move is to retreat
this bishop to d5 highlighting this rook
rook a7 and then after e6 the lines get
very very complicated
and black is more often than not going
to be worse
in these positions pretty significantly
so backing up
i took a look at the move knight takes
c5 and i think this is the way
to equalize with black here
um bishop takes c8 means queen takes c8
now knight d5 is really the only move to
try to press for an advantage
uh other moves are fine for white but if
just castles then black
is going to be able to castle himself
and from here
uh development shouldn't be too
difficult with the black king out of the
center
so knight d5 is the way to apply the
pressure in the position
obviously we're threatening this bishop
on e7 we're threatening
to go knight b6 and we're eyeing up
this king after moves like queen to e2
and so this is definitely the critical
move
to look out for uh
now i look looked at various options
here as well in
the two games that were played bishop c
or in the four games that were played
bishop c5
was black's choice in three of them and
bishop h4 check was black's choice in
one of them
and i do think actually this move bishop
h4 is going to be
uh the critical line here so bishop h4
check for black
g3 is the only move for white if he
doesn't want his king stuck
in these open open squares and now
bishop back to d8
is removing this bishop from threat on
e7 and protecting
the b6 square uh the obvious downside to
this
is we are leaving this knight just a
little bit stranded here
on e5 and so uh white's next move is
very very natural
you play the move queen e2 to try to
challenge this knight
uh now in the game we were following
between
uh nick speck who is a 2380 and
uh ivan shiparnov who was a 2550 at the
time of playing
uh chaparranov actually played the move
f6 and went on to lose this game
and i do think f6 gives white a
significant advantage
but the move knight d7 is the key move
here
for black and black is definitely not
out of the woods yet
this is like i said sort of the the
critical variation
and so this is where uh black is going
to have the most problems
and this is also where you're going to
have to kind of know know your stuff
so if white now sort of plays slowly
just develops a bishop
well a move queen c4 is going to be the
way to solve all of black's problems
you offer this trade of queens and you
can even castle on this turn or
after queen c4 as well and then black is
totally fine
so black needs or white needs to play
sort of immediately if he wants
to uh
to get an advantage here in this
position uh so john once again
we did this strange bishop maneuver we
go bishop h4
to force g3 to weaken the f3 square and
then come back to d8 because we want to
guard against knight b6
and also remove any ideas of knight
takes e7
knight b6 of course with with the fork
in many cases
so queen e29d7 and bishop f4 is one of
the two
critical moves here uh bishop f4 the
obvious point is we are challenging
this knight on e5 and at first glance
this is
very much not an easy issue to solve if
you play the move f6 here
trying to solidify it knight f5 is going
to kind of kill you
there's really not much that can be done
here after knight f5 if you castle
well look out this is also going to win
your queen
so the move here for black that you have
to find is the move queen c5
uh you sort of counter the threat to
your knight on e5 by threatening both of
white's loose knights
in the center and now after bishop takes
e5 you might think
that you know you sort of had an empty
threat because obviously
you cannot take here due to bishop d6
check
when you lose a full piece but you can
in fact simply castle and this is
uh sort of the the craziness of this
line is you allow white to capture this
knight
and you don't take it back immediately
uh the good news now for black
is white has too many problems to solve
to actually keep a hold
of this piece he has this knight hanging
on e4
this bishop uh about to be hanging on
if or sorry this knight hanging on d5
this bishop about to be hanging on e5
if the knight were to move and the queen
and king stuck in the center
on on the same file
so there's not much to be done here for
white to actually maintain
any sort of advantage if the bishop
retreats we're happy to capture this guy
now actually it's going to be white in
significant trouble
unable to castle queen side due to this
uh
and both of these pieces hanging so
white has to sort of find
some clever moves like queen e4
trying to defend everything and now the
obvious move is the correct move for
black you bring the rook
to the file put it opposite the enemy
king and queen
and pin this bishop as well now white
must castle or else he's going to be
worse if any other move like knight b3
challenging the queen
we are happy to offer a tree to the
queens here and then
simply collect our bishop back on e5
once again
this rook pinning the bishop to two
different pieces uh hello to
cabri uh nabil hello everyone
hello albert uh so queenside castles by
white makes the most sense removing the
king from the center
and uh bringing the rook to the d file
as well
and now one more slightly strange
looking move by black
and the game is is sort of over meaning
meaning black has totally equalized and
white will never really be able to get
any sort of advantage
and that move is knight f6 this is the
last key move
to find for black here and the point is
you are obviously attacking these two
pieces
and you're attacking this bishop as well
so if knight takes f6
bishop takes f6 and this pin is
maintained
along with this rook on a8 being well
defended
and then play might continue knight f3
uh bishop takes e5
and then one more trick by white rook d5
uh but of course this doesn't amount to
anything after bishop d6
unveiling a threat to the queen and also
cleverly defending
the black queen as well play might
continue with queen d3
queen e3 check takes takes takes takes
when we have an obviously drawn
obviously drawn end game here
uh if anybody's better it might be white
but this end game very very clearly
should be a draw
uh play might continue with rook d1
threatening checkmate
something like h5 uh something like b3
g6 and then both sides are going to aim
to activate their rooks
and it's actually black stroke on f3
that is sort of
uh really crucial here defending the f7
point
so any ideas of doubling on the seventh
rank aren't going to be
amounting to too much with this actively
play stroke
uh sort of dealing with those threats
well enough
uh you could never draw it well with
which side i think is a fair question
because this endgame should be pretty
pretty well drawn
uh okay so that was critical variation
uh number one in this line with bishop
f4
so once again bishop f4 key move defined
is queen c5
after bishop takes e5 this is the really
only move
for white if he tries anything else we
are collecting this free piece
and perhaps even saving this one so
bishop e5
now black must castle with the idea of
bringing the rook to e8s
now white must defend this knight on d5
if the knight moves
we can just collect our piece back so
queen e4 gets played
and now rookie 8 is the key move for
black
once again keeping the threat to both
these pieces white now has to castle
and now knight f6 and we are totally out
of the woods here
once again this sort of funny variation
to finish things off
okay
yeah one move nearly dick takes the
outcome of the game yeah these are
uh these are the kinds of positions that
that can crop up in the niter so
that was after the move uh bishop f4
this is sort of white's first try to get
any kind of advantage here going after
the knight on e5
and i think it's the most natural try
however white could also attempt the
knight f5 this move also looks rather
tempting
threatening knight d6 with check and
knight takes g7
is sort of a devastating threat at first
glance
what if instead of knight f6 rook takes
e5 uh yeah let me
show that really quickly if you take
this guy unfortunately the move 97
check is going to be be the issue here
uh with the rook on a falling now in the
previous lines whenever this knight
moved you could take here
and your rook defended your other rook
on a8 but this is not possible
after rookie five if knight takes e5
this is sort of playable
for black but rookie one is going to be
a small problem
when dealing with this uh pin to the
rook could end up
giving black a little bit of trouble so
knight f6 the simplest move
to to equalize now rather than knight f4
back to knight f5 and luckily for black
here the key move is the same move again
as against bishop f4
we need to play queen c5 this is really
just the best move that black
can play in these types of positions
activating the queen
threatening the powerful knight on d5 in
this case defending d6 and indirectly
defending
the knight on e5 as well
now once again white needs to sort of
deal with this piece
on d5 so the move queen e4 comes to mind
keeping this pin keeping these threats
and now black is simply going to castle
uh note if knight takes g7 here uh king
f8 is actually attacking two pieces
at the same time and so this is really
not going to be playable
uh if bishop h6 will take this guy and
now there's really no good discoveries
here
for white the king is going to run to uh
g8 and we are actually pretty well
defended on that side of the board for
the moment
and if a move like rook f1 king g8 is a
good move
for black anyways and if rook d1
something like queen c6 makes sense and
the white pieces are slowly
but surely going to have to start
retreating
one very forcing line for example rick
takes d7
you can actually take on h6 queen takes
e5
queen takes g7 check
queen f8 takes takes
either rook takes and black is
going to be slightly better here despite
the actively placed rooks
a full bishop is is a full bishop if
white tries to keep the peace for
example
uh well now you're sort of asking for
trouble with this bishop
and rook coming uh quickly into the game
uh okay so knight takes g7
definitely scary but i do think black
has enough options there where you can
sort of play your way out of it over the
board
because in the long run uh black is
going to be up a piece and is going to
have sort of just a winning position
uh if played well uh so queen c5 queen
e4
is the only move for white to not be
worse uh castles
bishop e3 makes sense to develop with
tempo
note now if something like bishop f4 we
are once again relying on this tactic
of knight f6 to sort of get us out of
dodge here
and this would in fact be good enough uh
if it takes
we will take if check we can take
uh and sort of take
uh with check and get our pieces
sort of to safety c3 rookie eight
and once again black is doing fine
so uh bishop e3 now the only move for
white really
queen c4 and this now offers a trait of
queens
and once again if we go into the end
game uh black is going to be doing well
after this move rookie 8 check king f2
uh and the reason i think black is going
to be doing pretty well here
is because the king sort of lacks safety
on the f2 square so if the black rooks
ever get active
which they likely will eventually this
king is going to be actually worse off
than the black king
that being said there are some very
concrete threats happening on the king
side
so black's gonna have to be a little bit
careful here uh
that being said there are a number of
moves that equalize
here with black you can simply offer a
trade of knights
when moves like knight takes g7 aren't
going to be playable due to this
and it takes bishop takes
or you can go for slightly more with a
move like g6
uh sort of dealing with this knight
immediately and now knight h6 check is
actually going to be a bit of a mistake
because these knights are going to come
back to the e5 square
and it's actually white's knight that
ends up in a little bit of trouble
in this variation uh okay
so obviously though white is not forced
to trade queens if bishop d4 now once
again the natural move rookie 8
is the way to go for black challenging
the king and queen along this e file
now queen side castles uh black uh
well sorry if white doesn't queen side
castle then once again
white is going to end up being a little
bit worse off in this variation
and the reason for that is for example
if white tries to be clever
and saves this knight attacking this
queen attacking this rook we have bishop
a5 check
and once again this king's gonna have to
move if he goes c3
knight d3 check is killer and so for
example
king f2 now if knight d3 check
white could capture so instead a move
like queen e6
saving the queen and once again it's
it's going to be white's king that's
actually worse off than blacks in this
variation
so after bishop d4 rookie 8 white
must queenside castle and then black can
go ahead and take on e2
and should take on a2 sorry a2 not e2
uh now after knight d7 check or
knight f7 check knight fe7 check
really they're the same they're the only
moves for white to not sort of lose
immediately due to all this pressure on
the queen side
uh we will capture of course to defend
our rook on a8s
knight takes e7 now we cannot take again
otherwise our rook would hang
but the move king f8 is playable and now
the only move for white once again to
not lose
is to take on h7 and now
if you're feeling dangerous you can go
ahead and take this knight
but it does turn out that this should
just be a draw
and so it makes a little bit more sense
to take a repetition immediately with
the move queen a5 here queen i won queen
a5
and white really has no way to deviate
otherwise uh
white will have a lost position for
example if something like c3 now king
takes a
e7 is going to be winning because we can
run to
the d file now since our opponent's king
is sort of interfering with his own play
here
uh and so this would end the game in
a draw so i know
that that was a a lot to cover but
those are really all the critical
variations involving bishop takes e6
here
once again let's review how we got here
right
we have of course the nightdorf the
sozen bishop c4
e6 bishop b3 bishop e7
and now f4 is sort of the most
aggressive try for whites
b5 e5 takes takes
knight back to e7 and now we're looking
at bishop takes e6 here
once again i think the only move for
black to equalize is knight takes e5
we see the bishop trade now knight d5 is
the attacking move to try to force an
advantage
we have bishop h4 check g3
uh bishop d8 queen e2
now not f6 but rather knight d7 is
the only move for black and now after
bishop f4
we go ahead and play queen c5 and castle
to get out of danger with rookie eights
and knight f6 to follow and then we have
this forcing line
that leads to an equal endgame
okay also instead of bishop f4
white could try the move knight f5 going
for threats like this
and the move queen c5 is going to be
good enough for black
if queen e4 we castle
bishop e3 queen c4 if bishop d4
once again rookie 8 is the way to go and
now white has to go for this forced line
with queen side castles or else he will
be a bit worse
as the black pieces untangle themselves
so queenside castles
we need two we saw a check
and takes and then this simple
repetition
okay so
i said before that these lines with
bishop takes e6 i think these are really
the critical critical variations
uh the move queen g4 i think is also
going to end up being critical
and so i'm gonna go over that one next
but uh
first does anybody have any general
questions about this bishop takes e6
stuff honestly
this is the one line that uh
kind of made me not want to recommend
these moves
because this one is quite forcing and at
the end of the day
it does end up in this equal end game
uh but black really has to know their
stuff or else black is gonna be
be worse here the reason i decided to
recommend it anyways
is because uh number one
players with the white pieces
historically have not played like this
very often
and number two there are just as many
chances
for white to go wrong and end up with a
worse position as there are
for black and so i think if you end up
in a position like this over the board
the better prepared player is going to
be the one
that ends up with the advantage uh so
if you think that's you i definitely
recommend going for these lines
if you don't think so if you don't want
to sort of put in
that little amount of work then you can
still play like this but just understand
after bishop takes c6 you're gonna have
a hard
task ahead of you
uh okay so
now let's look at the move queen g4 i
have another chapter for this
because there are also a lot of lines so
let's jump into it
uh we have the sozin e6 bishop e7
f4 b5 and now there are all these other
moves that i want to take a look at as
well
but we're still focusing on e5 de5 fp5
knight d7 now in the last chapter we
looked at all these lines with bishop
take c6 and knight takes e5
now let's look at queen g4 this is sort
of the the other critical line here
for for white
uh okay and the good news again for
black
is that the key move for black here is
the same as it was previously
and that of course is the move knight
takes c5 and i want to
just tell you straight up the move queen
g4 has
never been played in the database that
i've seen
and the reason for that is it's actually
going to be white
running a lot more risks than black
in in these variations that being said
uh
this is one of the the very very
forcing variations and if black doesn't
play well then black is
is going to be lost so we we should
definitely take a look at it here
but i just want to give you that preface
that this has never really been seen
over the board and this is all just uh
moves
of of my own making here so knight takes
e5
and now actually the only move for white
to not lose is the move queen e4
if you get a little greedy and try to
take this guy don't forget that this guy
is hanging
so bishop g3 or bishop f6 is going to be
good enough queen g3 cannot be played
due to this idea and if queen h6 uh now
this guy
is going to hang and this tactic saves
our own bishop
so queen takes g7 not playable only move
to not lose is queen e4
when we seem to have a fork but now i'd
like to
pose sort of a tactics puzzle to the
chats
uh what can we do here with black
there's only one move
to uh to not lose
how do you stop f4 by white in these
lines
well if you mean f5 we're going to take
a look at f5 uh
these lines in particular make f5
actually pretty bad
for for white which is why i'm kind of
saving them for later
because they're really not that good for
white even if they haven't been played
muhammad says queen c7 and that's
actually not quite it
in this case queen c7 is a good idea
normally to try and trap the queen
on a8 but in this case the bishop f4
is gonna sort of put an end to your
hopes and dreams
uh if this moved bishop d6 now all of a
sudden we take here
and if bishop c5 look out because
you have trouble on trouble on trouble
with with knight takes b5
and black is going to be lost after
queen c7
queen b6 i think runs into a lot of the
same issues the idea here
for black is actually the very
counter-intuitive bishop h4
check now why on this
earth is bishop h4 check the only move
to save the position
for black well the point is it's a bit
of a trap
white would love to play the move g3 but
after g3 white is of course
uh just much worse after the move
don't run queen takes d4
uh once again this bishop h4 check move
comes in handy
to weaken the white king's side in this
case directly
with tactics uh and here there's there's
simply no way
for white to to sort of come back into
this game
uh if white trades queens you have
knight f3 check king f2
it takes d4 g takes h4 and now
uh black is actually a pawn up with
these two pawns being very very weak
if g takes h4 we have something similar
here and
if the move queen takes a8 going for the
exchange
now the move knight e to c6 is once
again sort of corralling this queen
and we have a much much better version
of lines that we're looking at with
queen c7 directly
because our queen is very actively
placed and we have
right now a full piece in exchange for
the rook
if white gets greedy tries to take this
guy we take with check
go ahead and castle uh rook g1 there's
really no way
to even try to save this queen by the
way uh if something like this
we can just take back queen a3 this
isn't really helping
knight d4 and you're sort of just
checkmated unfortunately
um so rook g1 instead and now rook d8
and
black is going to have sort of a
crushing attack here
bishop g5 queen h3 check king e1
and there are plenty of moves now that
win for black
let's go with the simple rook d7 when
it's becoming clear
that the queen is is not actually going
to be saved
uh rook d1 would be an attempt to save
the queen but now queen takes h2
hits this guy knight 92 for example
bishop b7
and the end is is near for this queen
and a winning position for black
okay so all that in mind
white doesn't have to play g3 just
pointing out
that this g3 move is in fact sort of
just totally lost
for white or at least a very very
uncomfortable end game
down a pawn with these fractured uh h
pawns
so instead the only move for white to
not lose
is the move king e2 and that's why
i think this has never really been seen
over the board
because like i said your opponent has to
be very very very brave
if they want to play king e2 in this
position and they have to be very very
accurate if they're not going to lose
the game
unfortunately black also has to be very
very accurate
which is sort of the downside
if for example the move king d1
obviously this pins the knight and
knight c6 wins
if king f1 now queen f6 is going to be
check
knight f3 for example knight takes f3 g
takes f3
and just castles and once again white is
not
going to be in time to capture this
piece because queen d4
is just checkmating immediately uh
knight e4 for example
and now queen d1 check we chase the king
up the board
uh e5 check is good king takes h4
queen g2 threatening some checkmates and
we are
are starting to collect all of all of
white's pieces
while his king remains checkmated sort
of on the h4 square
so once again with accurate play black
white is never really able to capture
this rook on a8s
uh so king e2 instead and now b4 is the
key move
for black once again so in this position
rather than castle the king do any of
that save
either of our hanging pieces uh maybe
even retreat this bishop to a normal
square
we play the move b4 and that's that's
sort of uh the ridiculousness of this
variation
once again queen takes a8 is going to be
a huge mistake due to queen takes d4
and bishop e3 is not enough to save the
game because
queen g4 check is going to be very very
strong
and once again we can sort of retreat
back with this knight eventually
can also uh capture on c3
for example king f1 b takes c3 queen
takes b8
queen f5 check team g1 castles
and while black is very technically
down a rook for uh sorry just down in
exchange for the moment
of course black is going to be totally
winning here due to the placement of the
king
and the rook as well as the white queen
being totally out of the game
so once again white can never really
capture on a8 so b4
the uh really only move for
white is uh queen takes e5 or rook d1
followed by queen takes e5
uh so let's take a look queen takes e5
now b takes c3 to regain the piece
and rook d1 sorry rook d1 uh
of course this could happen in another
manner with rook d1 first
now b takes c3 and uh still
really the the move for white is going
to be the move queen takes e5 here
uh so that transposes and now we will
castle in this position uh and now this
is
you know sort of going even further down
the
rabbit hole
i look like bobby fisher interesting
i've i have not heard this one before uh
and now once again we are on move 15
and there are only two moves for white
that maintain the balance here
every other move ends up going in
black's favor
the simple one is knight takes e6 and i
think this is the much more natural move
that you would be likely to face here of
course this
is attacking many many pieces at the
same time black would be forced to play
queen f6
queen takes f6 bishop takes f6 knight
takes f8
and now we immediately regain the
exchange with bishop g4
for example uh king f2 or king e1
uh let's say king e1 for example bishop
takes d1
and now king takes d1 would be a bit of
a mistake due to c takes b2
uh so rook b1 would be the move
instead uh and now for example
a move like bishop g4 bishop d5
over k7 b takes c3
rookie 7 check king f2 bishop five
and it's it's actually going to be white
who has to work very very hard
to uh sort of extract this knight from
the position
also potentially possible for black is
to capture on b2 first
and this is going to end up in much
simpler variations
where we sort of save this guy uh
directly
although actually no it's not because
bishop d5 is a problem
so you would have to play king takes f8
here so never mind
me trying to give a simpler variation of
course uh
just play the complicated variation with
bishop g4 it should be fine
uh and once again it's it's really only
black who can be better here thanks to
the awkward position of this
knight okay so once again
that's after castles the simple
variation is 96
we develop our queen we go into this
forcing variation
and now after rook b1 there are sort of
a few different options
for uh black you can even take on
c2 and take on f8 and sorry this
is the simpler variation and now white
would have the two bishops
but uh black is going to have the better
pawn structure
and for the moment is technically up
upon
after this sort of variation okay
so 96 means queen f6 everybody's on
board
now the complicated variation is if
white goes queen e4
and this is uh sort of
a more of a losing attempt than a
winning attempt
uh it's important now for black to find
the move a5
which might not occur to you at first
but the idea is to simply checkmate the
white king in the center of the board
using these very powerful bishops and
now the only move for white that doesn't
lose
is to block this diagonal of course
if white captures on a8 we are happy to
give this
check rook d3 now is sort of forced and
we are already capturing here
the king comes up the board look out
queen f6 and queen f2
are sort of checkmating just for example
knight f3 grenade six
check and this king has no squares so it
comes up the board
and this is a king hunt if i've ever
seen one
and this guy is dying just
dying i tell you just dying look at how
daddy is it's terrifying
super super dead okay
so of course your opponent will not take
on a8 if they're smart and instead play
the move
bishop c4 really against anything here
bishop a6
is a good reply even like a4 bishop a6
check and you're winning for a lot of
the same reasons
uh if knight b5 knight d7
and the weakness of this king isn't
going anywhere
uh okay so a5 bishop c4 is the only move
bishop a6 now anyways bishop back to d3
is the only move now for white suddenly
creating threats on the other side of
the board
and now the fun forcing moves sort of
begin with the move
f5 hitting the queen uh now
if white doesn't want to lose he has to
take on f5 if queen f3 or queen e3 for
example will just simply develop
queen takes a8 of course we're still
taking on d4 and this is still winning
bishop takes a6 isn't good enough
because of
this
uh so f5 knight takes f5 is forced
i'm sorry queen f3 just queen f6 and we
are developing normally
so knight takes f5 is forced now we take
with check or takes d3
queen f6 and now white's only move is
knight h6 check
g takes h6 rook f3
queen g6 rick takes f8 king takes f8
and now white finally takes on a8 and
doesn't lose because of it
uh so now we have queen takes c2 check
uh king e3 or f3 and pretty much no
matter what
this is going to end up in uh either
a perpetual check or if black
can get the queen to the e5 square
defending the knight
then black can take on b2 and actually
be sort of marginally better
in an end game so for example king e3
bishop g5 check king f3 queen f5 check
king g3 green e5 check king h3
and now uh black could ever could either
try to repeat directly
with queen f5 queen d3 or take on b2
and go for this sort of end game uh
where he ends up with a knight in a
bishop
for a rook after something like f3 check
bishop f6 takes and takes
uh when neither side should really be
much better here
uh just another line if king f3 first we
can check
check check and now king takes h4 would
be a bit of a mistake
due to queen takes f4 and now once again
c takes b2
is going to be quite strong here for
black
uh okay so once again that line is after
castles if your opponent
is super daring they may play the move
queen e4
now your move is a5 to attack this king
in the center of the board
if bishop c4 bishop a6 and f5
then you get the queen outs take a free
nights
and go for this perpetual check
this is sort of the very very forcing
line for white to sort of escape
i honestly doubt anyone would ever
really face this over the board unless
they
they came in super prepared uh which is
why
i still feel comfortable recommending
these lines i just want to make you
aware
of their existence like this has never
happened in a game
but i do feel that these are some
critical lines in
this bishop c4 variation that i'm
recommending
which is why i feel the need to sort of
cover them in in detail because if you
don't know
anything going on here you're likely
going to get rolled over if
some guy with some home cooking comes at
you
uh and lastly if your opponent tries to
play something like knight f3
this sort of just loses to natural
development with with knight d7
uh queen e4 now we take the opportunity
to bring our bishop back into the game
and queen takes a is sort of not enough
after cb2
and bishop b2 when this is a comfortable
exchange sacrifice
with this queen threatened uh already
once again
on a8 uh
so there you go so any questions
on this queen g4 line once again
i think this is sort of more of a losing
attempt by white than a winning attempt
but black does have some moves that that
he needs to find that are sort of
counter-intuitive
which is why i felt the need to go over
this in depth
uh so queen g4 we take on e5 queen e4
give this check g3 is impossible because
the queen takes d4
king e2 instead now b4 is the key move
queen takes knight is forced b takes c3
rook d1
b castle knight takes e6 is the simple
line
green f6 trade trade take
check take and you end up in this end
game
or we have the move queen e4 when you
should play
a5 and checkmate the king in the center
of the board
with a fun little forcing variation to
arrive at a draw
a5 is so hard to find once you see it
though it makes a lot of sense which is
why i hope it'll stick out
because it really is just sort of
checkmating this king
in the center of the board
uh okay uh yeah g6 here is going to be
less good
because of actually now the move uh
knight f3
when this queen is sort of under threat
this bishop is under threat and it's
difficult to to solve all these problems
at once so you need to do something with
tempo which is why you arrive
at the move f5 okay
oh and g6 in this position is is kind of
just bad
because bishop h6 knight takes c6 still
queen e4 i think is a problem
uh a number of moves in this position
would be an issue
well apparently i picked a picture of
bobby fischer that really looks like me
i did not intend this but uh
sounds good i guess okay
so that was pretty much all of the
variations
after the move 8f4 and 9e5 which i
really think
is the critical variation against this
bishop e7
b5 setup we do have a little bit of time
left
so i'm going to try to go over uh some
sidelines
in this sort of variation so
bishop b3 bishop b7 f4 b5
now we've gone over pretty much
everything that happens after e5
but white of course has other options
besides e5 here
now i really do think e5 is the only way
for white to kind of keep the balance
and play for any kind of advantage
i think after every other move it's
actually black who's fighting for an
advantage here which is why i sort of
saved these
uh for the end so immediately you might
be tempted to play the move f5 with
white
but this simply allows the move e5 and
now black is going to be pretty
significantly better
this knight has to vacate it can come
back to e2
but now bishop b7 and already this e4
pawn is sort of a staggering weakness
now knight g3 would be required to
defend this pawn
knight bd7 though and we're coming out
to c5 and putting even more pressure
here
bishop g5 is already sort of required to
take away an attacker
but just a move like h5 is threatening
to take away
uh the knight from the defense of the
pawn for example bishop takes f6
knight takes f6 and uh black is
is sort of much much better here i think
the engine gives something like minus
1.3
uh and it's all because white structure
is sort of just horrible and awful
expect moves like rook c8 to follow
moves like queen c7 aren't bad as well
queen b6 is another option and we're
going to start pushing on the queen side
with moves like b4
and even a5 a4 threats in
some positions uh also keep in mind that
this bishop can get active in various
ways
it can come out on this diagonal can
actually occasionally come out this way
as well
depending on how the play progresses but
like i said
black should be the one for choice here
uh okay so that's f5 just not very good
for white if white castles here
uh then we transpose into some lines uh
where
white castles before playing bishop e3
so i'm gonna go all
over all of those sort of together at
the same time so we'll hold off on that
for the moment
if the move queen f3 uh then i like to
move bishop e7
just putting the bishop opposite the
queen and
after a3 this is sort of going to be
rather uncomfortable for white once
again
a3 of course stop b4 because we are
threatening to take on e4
we just play knight bd7 and white likely
has nothing better than to go for this
and this is sort of already just a worse
version of the same the queen on f3
is not really better than the queen on
d1
uh okay if bishop e3
this is sort of the most sensible move
aside from castling
uh the move b4 does really come to mind
now the knight will have to vacate to a4
and actually here knight takes e4 taking
the free pawn i think is a bit of a
mistake
so don't kind of fall into that trap
that's why i felt this line was
important to mention
if you take on e4 well the issue is
you're going to be met with the move
f5 uh and you're not really going to
have a good response to this
normally against f5 we liked to play the
move e5
but of course now the move uh bishop d5
is sort of going to be a huge issue here
that's not the only thing wrong though
also now the move knight e6 is going to
be powerful without this knight on f6 to
guard the key square
on d5 also also also this move might
even start coming to mind
for uh players with the white pieces
note
all of those lines here don't really
make any sense
because we can simply take everything
and here where there would be queen d5
if our knight wasn't here
there is no queen d5 and black is simply
winning
uh so bishop e3 a bit of a trap to
take this guy because f5 is quite strong
but we can develop simply with the move
castles
castles and bishop d7
and now the point of bishop d7 is we are
finally threatening to actually take
this guy
for example if white passes we take on
a4
and take on e4 and this is just an extra
pawn
now there's no bishop here to give us
problems
and we should be doing uh quite well in
fact
if white passes we could actually take
here first and
uh sort of just keep this threat in our
pocket of taking on a4
because now all of these moves are going
to be a little bit worse
due to the fact that this knight is
hanging on a4
at the end so bishop d7 actually makes a
threat here
which means it's probably time for white
to just kind of
bear down and defend this pawn and then
we can switch to normal development with
something like knight c6
uh just for example play might continue
c3 take on d4
take on d4 bishop c6 c takes b4
and after something like rook b8 and a5
uh once again i think black is going to
be
a bit better here with uh black
definitely regaining this pawn on the
queen side
and pressure uh on the e pawn as well
uh okay so those are sort of
those sidelines after the move f4 b5
the one i haven't mentioned so far is a3
which is also sort of a reasonable move
but i do think black can get a slight
edge after something like bishop b7
going after the e4 pawn once again and
now if queen f3 we would transpose to
this line that we've looked at
with uh let's see what did i recommend
with knight bd7 and f5 e5
uh and if white tries something
else here uh for example queen e2 would
be a better try not to step onto this
diagonal
or a move like yeah let's let's say
queen e2
has anything else really been played no
not really
queen e2 now this would be a bit of a
trap if we played the move knight bd7
because we actually sort of need this
square for our knight
so rather than knight bd7 simply castles
uh cat uh and now if f5 e5
and if castles by white
uh we can finally play the move knight
bd7 uh thanks to the fact
that we have some tactics to our name
having to do with the knight on d4 for
example e5
means takes takes and bishop c5 is
already going to be
quite good it should be 3 queen v6
if rook to d1 for example we can already
take this guy
if takes on f6 for example we simply
take here
and are doing quite well
okay and if f5 we still
fall back to e5 and are happy to go with
our usual counter play
against the e4 pawn and now i kind of
want to stress this
in this move f5 has been played 11 times
which i think leads to a direct
advantage for black after e5 and bishop
b7
as i said castle's been played 10 times
which i also think is good for black
after bishop d7
and e5 has only been played nine times
which falls into those critical
variations that i was
was talking about uh and so
more than two out of three times here uh
players with the black pieces
have ended up with an advantage now if
your opponent really knows their stuff
and they know that e5 is the best move
here you will have to be
a little bit prepared but i think more
often than not you're going to be
playing against
players using sort of sub-optimal
variations here and it's very easy to
just get an advantage
you know you develop these pieces so so
naturally and the e5 pawn often just
falls off the board
so that's why i really like recommending
this line for black
now we are just about out of time for
tonight so i wanted
to uh briefly mention everything we've
gone over
we've gone over the lines with first
bishop b3 here
and now after f4 b5 i think we have
covered
uh pretty much everything aside from the
castle's
variations uh in this line
uh so this is sort of the position that
i have
totally totally covered so if there are
any questions from
this position forward let me know now
uh other than that i'm going to briefly
now mention what i haven't covered and
what you can expect
in the next lecture and then i think
we're going to call it here
so as for things i haven't covered
there's actually a critical move
g4 in this position that i want to go
over
there's also all the variations
involving castles
including the ones where white castles
immediately and
also there are some variations to look
at here with just
something like bishop e3 and other
sidelines
so basically sidelines including quiet
moves like bishop e3 just developing
the variations where white castles early
and the move g4
in this position are the ones left to
cover
um why not queen f3 move eight uh yeah
we can talk about queen f3 as well
uh but that's also going to have to be
for the next lecture i think in general
it's not so good to blockade
this pawn in and we will talk a little
bit about this maneuver but you normally
see this after white has
has already castled uh okay
so thank you very much for joining me
tonight
for this part one lecture of the bishop
c for susan
the lines i went over tonight are really
the heaviest lines
theoretically wise so if you survived
this lecture
and you're still interested in playing
these lines as black
the rest should be a piece of cake after
bishop c4
uh isn't bishop g5 also an option bishop
g5 has been played eight times here
uh and yeah i'm likely going to end up
covering
this as well but it is a bit of a
sideline g4
and the castle's variations are the main
main stuff for next lecture
um okay so thank you all so much for
joining me here tonight
hopefully you enjoyed this lecture if
you're watching live be sure to check us
out on the twitch channel right after
this where i will be back
with a tactics class it's tactics time
tonight
uh if you're watching the youtube video
that's all for tonight once again thank
you so much for joining me
uh my name is kale denby i will see you
next time